-Brie and I are about to compete
in a virtual reality game called
"Beat Saber."
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, dang.
-Now here's how --
We have the Kool-Aid Man
in the audience.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah!
-Oh, yeah.
All right, we're going to take
turns using laser swords
to slash targets
to the beat of a song.
And we'll see who can get
the highest score.
[ Laughter ]
I'll go first.
Please root for me, sir.
[ Laughter ]
All right, I'll go first.
-Oh, wait, is this for you?
-Yeah, oh, thanks.
-Yeah, get that on.
-Appreciate that.
-Maybe step on your mark
before you put it on,
because you won't be able
to see?
-Oh, yeah, that's true.
-Now, be careful now.
-All right, thank you.
Ooh. All right.
-Okay, this one's left.
-Okay.
-This one --
No, this one's right.
-Oh, gotcha.
-That's my hand.
That's my wrist.
[ Laughter ]
-I wanted to hold your hand.
I'm sorry.
All right.
-All good.
-All right, so here we go.
Ready?
-You got this!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah, he's doing great!
-Hyah! Hyah! Hyah! Hyah!
-Slice it!
-Hyah! Hyah! Hyah!
Hyah! Hyah! Hyah! Hyah!
-Wow!
-Hyah! Hyah! Hyah! Hyah!
Hyah! Hyah! Hyah! Hyah! Hyah!
Hyah! Hyah! Hyah! Hyah!
Whoa!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
Whoa!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoa!
Watch out for the walls!
[ Music stops ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wow, wow, wow!
Are you okay, man?
Seems like you've been
through some stuff.
-Do you have any --
Do you have any water?
Does anybody have any oxygen?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
Wait till you do this, man.
This is insane.
-I just took my shoes off.
I saw how real you were
getting in there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo!
-All right, it's now
Brie's turn.
You put on your headset
and then I'll...
-Okay.
-...give you the controllers.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here we go.
This is the left controller.
No, that's the left.
-Yep.
-And here's the right
right here.
That's my hand. I just wanted
you to hold my hand.
Sorry, sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-Was yours hard, too?
-Yes, mine was tot -- Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Hmm!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-♪ I've been in another world ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I've been livin' free ♪
♪ I don't know what to do
or say ♪
♪ But I know what I need ♪
-You're really good.
-♪ If you want to escape
with me, come take my hand ♪
-Wait, whoa! That was awesome!
-♪ Let me show you another way
to a better land ♪
♪ A better land ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa!
♪♪
-Oh!
-Oh, my gosh! Oh!
[ Music stops ]
That is how you do it.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dude, you were holding --
you were holding a lightsaber.
It was burning the screen!
Our champ right there,
Brie Larson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, that was so awesome!